donnie darko is directed by richard
kelly and stars jake gyllenhaal and the
4k restoration is currently being
released in theaters and i got to see it
last night as a nightlight Theatre in
Akron this film is a favorite of mine
but the first time I saw it
not so much I got the DVD of it when I
was like 15 years old and I watched it
and I remember thinking ooh this is a
movie with the guy from October sky and
it's about a bunny monster this could be
cool bunny monsters after my initial
viewing it's safe to say I had
absolutely no idea what this movie was
about and it took me many years to
really grow to appreciate it and today
it's one of my all-time favorite movies
after many re watches and many
explanation readings and all kinds of
theories of my own as well and reading
what's available of the book philosophy
of time-travel which is featured heavily
in the movie it's a fictional book of
course but that definitely helped me
understand the film quite a bit what is
this show about well we have a guy named
Donnie Darko played by Jake Gyllenhaal
as I said and he is getting visions of a
bunny named Frank who seems to tell him
that the world is going to end very soon
he gives him strange apocalyptic visions
he gives them strange abilities he tells
him to destroy things he tells him to
upset the balance of his town because
something very bad is going to happen to
the world if he doesn't and along the
way we go through a lot of rebellious
teen phases and girls and teachers and
family troubles and all kinds of things
that you would expect to see in a film
that takes place in the 80s because this
takes place in 88 and a lot of really
great movies in the 80s dealt with youth
and the rebellious stages that we all
sometimes go through and most of them
were directed or produced or written by
John Hughes even the first time I saw it
and I was like what there was something
about the film that I just could not
stop watching it was transfixing it's
beautifully shot the acting is extremely
good and even if you don't fully grasp
the story on the first viewing you can
still watch it as a movie about a
rebellious kid dealing with possibly
schizophrenia or strange dreams or
simply that there's a ghost around like
the first time you see the movie that's
kind of what you
latch onto like it's prank just a ghost
is he going insane is he just nuts off
with the meds he's taking what is this
movie really about is it a metaphor for
the rebellious stages that we go through
and we're a teen and the things that we
do and people who say that you know the
devil made me do it
and things like that and the first time
I saw it I remember being like okay well
that's what I can instantly kind of
grasp but then there's this weird thing
with a jet engine that falls on his
house and a time portal and is the thing
that looks like the thing in the abyss
coming out of people's chests what the
hell is going on its movie so it took me
quite some time to really truly
appreciate it and now sitting here today
after a lot of research this is one of
my favorite movies I think Gyllenhaal is
fantastic in this movie also Seth Rogen
has his film debut as a complete asshole
and his first line is literally this I
like your boobs so that pretty much
shaped the rest of Seth Rogen's career I
think the soundtrack is also euphoric
and not just the songs that they chose
for the movie but the score the song
manipulated living is so creepy I listen
to that quite often it's a very cool
beat this movie isn't just a very smart
film that delves into really odd things
about time and different universes it's
also an extremely well-made film
technically the sound the visuals the
acting everything about this movie can
be appreciated at least to look at even
if you're not fully grasping the movie
you can look at Bonnie Darko the film
and just be mesmerized by it as talk
about Patrick Swayze rest in peace and
his incredible instructional videos
there's one specific shot that just had
me in tears laughing where boom Mike
comes into view those instructional
videos remind me of every horrific
annoying video that I had to watch in
school about math or science or feeling
good about yourself it's so well
portrayed very accurately recreated this
film which leads me into this is
actually really funny I forgot we
watching it last night just how funny
this movie is the audience was laughing
quite often there's a lot of great jokes
there's a lot of really good references
to thing
that we can understand because we've all
been through that stage or we've seen
things like that my favorite scene in
the film is probably the fear versus
love scene where Donnie is talking to
this teacher who's trying to lump
everything into two categories that of
fear and love and he's like it's not
that simple
you can't just lump everything into two
categories that doesn't make sense it's
one of the best scenes in the film I
also love when Donnie goes off the deep
end and starts talking to Patrick Swayze
about how insane he is in front of
everybody and how he's I cried my god
there are so many amazing sequences in
this movie and then there's all this
time-travel stuff and a guy in a bunny
suit and somebody gets shot and you
don't know exactly what's going on
there's two universes maybe in a whole
bunch of universes I don't know it's
crazy
Donnie Darko is so great it's one of my
favorite movies I highly suggest seeing
and if you never have but just be
prepared for the fact that the film
really doesn't make sense that much
unless you really start to read into it
I really only have one issue with Donnie
Darko and a lot of it has to do with
that initial viewing that I had and with
recommending it to some of you who may
have never seen it it's that on first
viewing the theatrical cut really
doesn't give you all of the info you
need to figure the film out you actually
have to do some reading afterwards or
watch the director's cut which has
excerpts from that book philosophy of
time travel included in the film without
that you really don't know what he's
talking about also there's a good
commentary from Richard Kelly that helps
to understand the film a lot more but a
film that's this confusing needs to kind
of have some puzzle pieces in it so that
you can go I got it
just watching the theatrical once you
can't fully grasp the movie you have to
do the homework assignment and that's
not really great that's my one issue
with this film I love it all these years
later because I do feel like I
understand it and I'll talk a little bit
about my theory after I give my grade
for those who haven't seen the movie I'm
going to give Donnie Darko and A+
that's right I'm giving it my perfect
grade despite the fact that I have that
one issue with the movie because all
these years later I love it so much and
it has really inspired an entire
generation to look at film from an
analytical perspective and you cannot
deny that it did it for me and it's done
it for a lot of other people too
so spoilers what are my theories on this
movie well I subscribe to the popular
theory that when the jet engine falls
into Donnie's room in the beginning this
causes a tangent universe a separate
universe from the present-day universe
and during this time period Donnie is
led by Frank the bunny or Frank in a
bunny suit
who he later kills in this tangent
universe now due to all the time-travel
stuff this person is able to come back
in time and lead Donnie through various
situations that he has to get into to
eventually get to the point where he can
put the jet engine where it has to be to
get back to the present-day universe
gretchen played by jenna malone is also
dead and she towards the end of the
tangent universe is killed and she is
also somehow coming back in time and is
being manipulated by somebody up there
to get Donnie to do all the things he
has to do perfectly to get the tangent
universe back to the actual universe
because if he doesn't these are all
going to collapse on each other in the
universe will end Wow that's in the
philosophy of time travel book and it
requires reading and thoughts and
Richard Kelly has talked a lot about
this there are alternate theories but
just the fact that Richard Kelly has
talked so much about it and that book
itself leads me to subscribe to that
notion that this is just a tangent
universe because I mean the book talks
about whoever the living receiver is who
is the person who's supposed to get
through this time period to work out
everything in this tangent universe to
get back to the actual one having like
abilities and powers like super-strength
how else would Donnie get the axe inside
the brass dog head it's also talked
about that he would have telekinesis and
he would have the ability to rip the jet
engine off of the plane with telekinesis
if necessary there's a lot of things in
this movie
that are absolutely mind-blowing and
there's other alternate theories but if
you really look into some of those like
maybe it's a time loop going over and
over again and Donnie just has to keep
trying to do everything perfectly
there's way too many plot holes for that
to make sense to me one of my biggest
issues with that is that the notion that
everyone in this tangent universe is
just kind of acting or in a play
basically to get Donnie to do things I
don't view it like that at all I think
they think they are in a real world and
they don't fully realize that they are
being manipulated by a higher source to
get Donnie to do everything he needs to
do like when Drew Barrymore is in her
class and she's like cellar-door are the
two most beautiful words in the English
language and then later
Donnie finds his cellar door knows he
has to go in there like those things I
don't think Drew Barrymore was just
waiting for him with those words on the
board I think somebody made her do that
but she didn't look at it like I'm in a
play or I'm in a weird world where I'm
forcing Donnie to do things or Gretchen
for instance I think she really is
falling for Jake Gyllenhaal and a higher
source is making her do everything that
she has to do to get him to be in a
place where he has to be because he
wouldn't kill Frank the bunny if Frank
the bunny hadn't run over Gretchen and
then Frank the bunny can go back in time
to instruct Jake Gyllenhaal to do what
he's got to do to get the tangent
universe to go away and there's so many
little things like that that all fall
into place and if you really get to head
on with it it's like oh my god do I even
like this movie anymore what is this
movie what is happening right now I
adore it I love it I love everything
about Donnie Darko it's one of my
favorites I want to say thank you so
much to the awesome fans we came out to
the showing to say hi to me that was
really humbling Nick great to meet you
Trevor great to meet you as well
Hector thank you very much for saying hi
to me and good luck with your wife's
pregnancy I hope your baby comes along
very well and that your future with her
is great thank you so much to the
awesome guys who came up to me too
who asked me to randomly be in the intro
for their chips review and I was like
sure why not everyone I met and I'm so
sorry if I forgot someone's name I'm so
so sorry
there were a few people there I couldn't
remember everybody thank you so much
guys it was really cool to meet you as
always you guys are the best thank you
very much for watching I was going to
post my aliens review today that
has been pushed to Tuesday due to this
film thank you guys once again if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]